(Quietly) Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Totally Accurate Battle Simulator
Now this is definitely the first time i've tried this stream, and uhhh-
I definitely haven't failed miserably getting  this up and out to everybody, out there.
But as it stands, right now-
(Speaking to the stream) Ohh no...Nah I'm good! I'm good! Nah it's good!
(Speaking to the stream) Nah I'm good! I'm chill! It's all good! Yeah, no, it's good.
(Speaking to the stream) Is it good? No, it's not good...Is it good? It might be good...(Make up your mind Mark Good lord!)
(Speaking to the stream) Hang on, let me see something...Is it good? *mumbles* Ooh, that don't look good...
(Speaking to the stream) How about a little bit of that? Blam! Cool? Is that cool?
(Speaking to the stream) Oh please don't tell me that's not cool! OHH NOO!!
(Speaking to the stream) PLEASE DON'T TELL ME THAT'S NOT COOL!!
(Speaking to the stream) That better be cool...'Cause if that ain't cool, I'm gonna start punching a bunch of people....
(finally notices us) Hi! How's it goin' everybody? I'm not gonna punch you guys!
You don't need to worry about that, but I'm - uh - I'm just
trying to get thing - everything situated here
(Speaking to the stream) So, if you guys are able to see this and everything is hunky dory
(Speaking to the stream) let me know
(Speaking to the stream) It's good?
(Speaking to the stream) It's good?!
(Speaking to the stream) It's good?!?! (yes, Mark, it's great)
(Speaking to the stream) It's good??????(YES ITS FUCKING GOOD!!!)
(Speaking to the stream) You guys better tell me it's good
(Speaking to the stream) Is it good?
(Speaking to the stream) You guys are saying it's good
(Speaking to the stream) It works, hell yeah!
Finally! I don't even know what the hell I changed
but I did a whole bunch of things, I flipped switches up and down
a whole bunch, I'm a professional flip-switcher
bkupcha - PINK - ah, I got the switch flipped
okay, good
It's on and it's here and it's hella and it's awesome
So, that being said I know that things are gonna absolutely break
as soon as I get into this game, but you know what?
I'm not even gonna bother with worrying about that
because it's time.
It's time figure out exactly what we need to do
to beat ever-loving shit out of these people
which is gonna come down to
I - me thinks, me thinks it's gonna come down to
something...Trump?
I can't even afford that! Trump and Hillary? (needs a small loan of a million dollars)
Oh, yeah, you're SO funny there /s/
Darkpeasant?
Oh God, well that sounds horrifying
But what it's gonna come down to is definitely
hmm
You know what? I'm gonna go for barrel rollers again
because that actually, that actually worked well
but what I need to do is I need to dedicate two
for the sides and then the rest just needs to be able to mop up the shields
so they can be the stabby stabs
Yeah
Yeah, and one behind the pillar you know all sneaky like
no one's ever gonna see him coming by
Yeah [devious voice], okay so we're gonna get started on that
Cool? Alright, now this is gonna work [sure it will]
I promise you - no, don't, don't, don't just go for the same ones
[devastated] noooooooo
No-o-o-o-o, I put 'em too close together
Oh no! Oh, this one is slightly charred
okay, that did not work because the barrel rollers
didn't - ah - do it correctly
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna stagger 'em
Like this, no not like, not like that
No wait, there we go
Like that, and then we're gonna have musketeers
way in on the sides like that
Maybe like, maybe like that. There we go.
we're gonna beat 'em on distance
cuz we got nothing else to beat 'em on
it doesn't help when you - dude, dude
oh, he's trying to get a lau- WWE move he's gonna
slam down upon them, and then you're both gonna hit
at the same time, just like I didn't want
[long, frustrated sigh]
You all suck
These guys are assholes
This is not representative of what my army would be like
if I were to actually do this
so you sacks of shit
ya just died and you're no good to anybody anywhere
so congratulations, it didn't fricken work
anyway, so
Hello everybody, hi guys, hi! How's it going?
Welcome back to the stream
glad you all could make it here
uhhh supposedly everything is working now
if it's not, I can't fix it. I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna deal with it because some people
it is working and I don't know what else to do about it
So, oddly enough I almost got it done, uh
I almost had it
uh when I was uhm, when I was, uh
I - I almost had it when I was just doing barrels
like, only barrels, I oddly enough almost had it
So, I'm gonna try to do something completely different here
which is literally just gonna beeeee....
hmm, we need, we need distance is what we need
we need a little bit of distance
so maybe spears would be good
maybe spears, cuz, like that way they can just poke em
from an incredible distance
and then supposedly that's gonna be good question mark?
I could afford one barrel roller?
Well that's not gonna be good when we got these guys here
So I'm gonna put that there and them I'm gonna put
the spear men right up behind them
so hopefully we can take care of the shields
if the barrel's gonna go a little faster than that
there we go, [sing-songy] here comes death
for my guys as well because they charge in, then fire and they burn and die
[exasperated sigh] that didn't go as planned
mmm it doesn't help when they're not very accurate with those spears
well that guy just threw away that guy's weapon
aaaaaaand he died. Promptly.
very promptly, just fell and died
but not bad, not bad, not bad, not bad, not bad
not bad, alright
so my mistake was putting the, the barrel roller there
so I'm going to get a bunch of uh
I'm just gonna go all out spear men here
and I know this is just gosh darn embarrassing for you
pro-level uhhh Totally Accurate Battle Simulator players
but you know, for me... wow
Wow...
You serious about that?
You think that rock is an imminent threat to the Greek empire?
Uh...
No it's not.
Okay guys
Alright
You're an embarassment to everything.
[ok]
Yo-- [Enemy jumps over pillar]
[Laughter]
Woah!
How-- I don't know how you climbed on that-- [Laughter]
Aww geez...
[Mission failed! We're gonna get them next time...]
Well this is going poorly for me.
Maybe some day I'll get off my ass and actually be able to do  do something good here...
alright fine,
you wanna do this in this-- in this way?
We're gonna do a samurai...
[  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ]
[HIRE A SAMURAI]
Just straight up 'sams'.
'Aight go for 'em.
This seems good because they're crusaders and we got helmets--
[A samurai is being dumb.]
...Whyyy?
[Samurai shrugs his incompetence off.]
What happened to you?
[Samurai holds the Japanese Invisible Katana™]
Wha-- Where'd your sword go?
[Laughter]
What are you doing?
[The Great Battle of 6:46-7:04 happens.]
I dunno what the hell happened here but it did not go well.
Alright, so
Uhh
I think the conclusion here is (that) samurai suck.
[*Gasp*]
And
Uhh
That's no good.
Alright
Fine
You know what? We're going to go all ranged then!
[Oh no...]
Where's the-- Wasn't there just a...
Where's the little...like...the poachers with the tiny little twigs that they were shootin'?
Like the toothpicks?
Do they not have those anymore? Alright, we're gonna go, Archers.
*Mark making a very weird noise*
And then I'll put on the hill.
Hill Archers, let's get a few more on the hill
Get some height advantage here, because they can't climb up here as long as my guys don't charge down there I should be fine. Right? They're not gonna charge?- they're gonna charge.
Oh, you're an embarrassment to everything that I'm doing.
Oh, you are the biggest embarrassment I've ever seen.
Okay, good job guys, you're gonna shoot through your own guys and kill each other aren't ya?
Yup, ya' are! Oh my god!
How many arrows in our ass do we have?
This guy has an arrow straight up his right butt-cheek, which, you know, great aim for this guy but not very good for everybody else.
Yeah, they're- they're an embarrassment.
They're an absolute embarrassment to everything.
Yup, this was a bad idea.
Now let's try this again.
I'm gonna get this guys, you guys don't believe in me and you guys think that I'm just a big old doof here, but I- I have an idea of what I'm doing. So if you guys could just, you know, calm down.
We got this.
Because I'm pretty sure
I have the six strap, with the barrels
And then I just need to be able to follow up
With other people, and I think that these, are gonna be a real stabby bunch.
So long as they're far away enough from the fire not get dead.
So come on, don't- don't- don't embarrass me, BOOM!
Nice, nice, walk through the fire and then follow up with the footmen, or the thieves.
Yeah, stab!
Well, you didn't stab enough, oh it's close!
Oh, it's not close- *gasp* OOH! Did you see that sweet uppercut he didn't even have a sword?!
Mm!
I did it!
I did it! I did it!
Yay, I did it! I can't believe I did it, I finally- Oh is this it?
Oh, you got archers this time.
Okay, I think I'm still gonna do a Barrel Roller right here because that seems like a good idea.
And then I'm gonna have
My Thieves- No, no, my Ninjas- No, no, my Kickers.
Coming up the-
Coming up the flank here, got a whole lot of kicking going on here.
Then we're gonna- we're gonnaaa....
Ninja our way over here! Wait, what was that?
Alright, we're gonna Ninja our way
Right up your other flank and you're never gonna see them coming!
So, Barrel Roller in time and then they're not even seeing them coming! *Markifart*
Alright, then fling flong, fling flong, fling, fling, fling, flong fling. Woah, dude.
Okay, I know you're a Ninja and all and that's very impressive but,
*Chuckling*
Why are you doing that?
Whoa.
That was close, this guy's a survivor.
Is he? No, he's not.
No, he's absolutely not a survivor.
Not in any capacity.
Alright, so it's those archers that are gonna be good-
I didn't even see what these guys did, but i'm pretty sure they didn't do anything.
Sooo let's beat them at their own game..
..with head-butters.
MORE head-butters.
Cause they got a lot of health, so, I mean-
They're gonna be able to take some of the, some of the arrow shots.
And, hopefully, close the gap.
Ohhhhh, I was right.
ohmygod
Oh whoaohoh, my god..
whohohohohoho
I should have just been using head-butters from the beginning because those guys are amazing.
What is this? What?
What?
What's wrong? *giggling*
What happened to them?
Are they ok..?
Guys, what happened to you?
What happened to these poor, lost souls?
Oh my god, why are their eyes way up there?
Oh- I have no idea...
Alright, well, these guys are all the different variations of what happened to you-
after you go into a meat grinder.
OR you star at a certain SCP and he mashes you into mashed-potatoes and pulp.
So, uh..
Yeah, a lot of musketeers huh? So I'm gonna go with head-butters again.
*Odd mouth noises*
Oh, another row? Hell yeah-
*More odd mouth noises*
Oh, one more small row? This is the third regiment, just in case.
*Mouth sounds*
There we go, good enough. Go for it.
Jeezums, look at this friggen- whOOOaaa
Alrighty then..
Oh, didn't even faze me- you assholes, you possesed demons are gonna get it
Oh man, I think that guy dove straight into a musket bullet.
Ohh
Head-butters are undeniable!
Head-butters are unbelievable!
Awe man, ok, alright then.
Uhhhhh, head-butters?
I don't know... what else would I use?
What's this? Oh you're giving me all that money, let's get some head-butters up on the pyramid here.
Yeah, just, you'll never see them coming.
There's a bunch of people that are gonna jump into the pit and-
Oh yeah, this is the flanking regiment of head-butters over here.
Yeah, ok, alright then.
Don't worry, my computer can handle this.. maybe...
oof
Let's get a perspective of how this looks.
Uh huh, not scary? Oh that's terrifying over there.
Oh, yeah, can't beat em'
mm nope mmhm
Who'd have known,
that if, all throughout history if people would have put on viking helmets-
(Not REAL viking helmets, fake-o viking helmets.) And then-
started smashing their heads into the skulls of their enemies, then they would have won instantaneously .
Oh what's this? Oh what's this?
What are you saying? Are you saying you got... head-butters?
You talking about head-butters?
Secret head-butters over here, they're gonna be like, "Huh, they only have a small head-butter army."
Little do they know, they're stupid and assholes.
Head-butters? Does your shield withstand my head-butt?
HEAD-BUTT
Ohh, no.
Head-butt too stro-o-o-o-ong.
WHOA
Head-butt too STRANG for you-
Here they come! The zombies flying in.
Oh- oh no, they got a chicken peasant.
TAKE HIM OUT!
Oh, shit..
Oh no
I shouldn't have spread my butt.
Jesus.
The chicken man too powerful.
Why do they get a chicken man? That's just unfair...
Right, you know what?
My problem here was that I was spreading my forces too thin.
So we're gonna concentrate all my forces in just, hopefully one catapult killable area .
So that one catapult strike is gonna devastate our entire army.
I have no idea what I'm doing, I am not a good military planner
in any capacity. In fact, I'm drunk and high on the job and all my soldiers are gonna die.
Here we go!
Missed me, oh-
I mean- you hit a lot of me but you missed most of me.
Ok, well this was not a good idea.
Come on guys, you got some stragglers left!
Oh my god.
Did that guy tank that frickin catapult?
*In strange accent* Ohh, that peasant is too strong! Get him!
How's he- how are you still alive?
Oh, good, he's dead. Ok, who do I got left?
Alright, just enough to win apparently.
Yaaay, go me!
Oh, ice
Uh oh
I have a funny feeling that, eventually, I'm going to be facing some head-butters myself.
Which I don't think is going to go very well for me.
*Wierd mouth sounds*
Alright, there we go.
And this is the Markiplier way, once you find a winning strategy you hold onto that and never let go until the end of your days.
No matter what you do, no matter who you are, no matter where you go in life-
you head-butt and then you head-butt and head-butt.
Head-butt all your problems, this is patented Markiplier advice right here.
Head-butt your enemies until they absolutely can't do anything at all-
and, uh, you win.
(I think)
(I'm pretty sure)
Pretty sure that's how that goes.
Maybe? I have no idea.
But anyway! So, head-butt away.
Please tell me I'm not gonna- oh no.. oh no...
Oh no
Head-butters and axers?
That's, you know, that's actually a lot of things to deal with-
I don't- I don't much appreciate what you're putting up against me because that seems like it's gonna be something
that's not gonna be good for me.
Because I can't... I can't, I don't know If I can deal with that.
I don't know how to deal with something without head-butting so I'm gonna just head-butt...
And beat em' with superior butt numbers.
Cause if I know one thing about myself, It's that I got a superior butt and I drew a tampon-
Ok, here we go.
Come on.
Get your butt-heads out  of the way-
and we're gonna butt you in the head.
Oh shi- *laughter*
It's just a bunch of people diving into each other over and over again
Oh, incredibly hilarious.
To- to know- oh my god
Oh, they're unstoppable.
I think the problem is that the head butters don't actually do all that much damage
there benefit is that they  knock them over so that they can pin em' in
ohhhh *chuckles*
yeah that's no good
okay so that didn't work
oddly enough
who would'a thought
can't head butt all your problems away
so let's try to Archerize this.
And what we're gonna do this time is we're not
gonna make it so that we shoot our own people.
Even though I've exactly set this up so that we can shoot our own people...
Uhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh (pitch slowly descending)